je vous je présente je présente mon fils
il est marrant hein il va se réveiller
d'un moment à l'autre vous allez voir E
vous allez voir non mais ça va
pas et alors ah ça y est il me fait une
risette il m'a
reconnu et
alors oh mign il pleure jamais hein ah
vraiment il est facile à élever il a que
6 mois vous me direz al tu V pas me
contredire devant tout le monde hein
veuxtu te TER ve tu te TER petit Boyou
écoute écoute-moi écoute quand tu auras
20 ans tous les hommes seront frais ton
prochain sera ton
ég tu auras des gar en blanc et un gros
hélicoptère car tu seras
caporal général à
cheval et àada sur ton beé avec ta
grande ép t auras des galons et un beau
chapeau
[Musique]
pointu qui me fich que que c'est de
faire peur au chabaés au lieu de faire
sa
risette qui m'a fich des Bab qui font
Jumo et Bambi et les petites
marionnettes
qui et part après TR
pirouettes quand tu auras 20 ans il y
aura une jolie dame dont tu seras prince
charmant tu auras 30 de D et quand tu
diras César ses bras s'ouvriront tout
grands pour 6
mois pour 20 ans tu seras dans le secret
des demoiselles comme polyin tu feras
joujou en voilà en
[Musique]
veux-tu
ta vie en fin de compte ce sera un
compte et la pébette monte monte monte
monte monte monte quand tu auras 20 ans
les hommes seront intelligents on
attrapera la lune dans 20 ans tu auras
ans tu auras 20 ans
voisure et moi j'auraai 20
ans de plus
et moi j'auraai 20 ans de
[Musique]
plus